françois bayrou est ce que vous êtes
inquiet face à la candidature pécresse
on va parler tout à l'heure de votre
rapport comme haut commissaire au plan
sur la réindustrialisation mais d'abord
un sondage et lab notre sondage ifop
hier et un sondage et la bourde hui qui
donne valérie pécresse qualifier au
second tour et même qui battrait
emmanuel macron souvent tôt je vais vous
dire il y avait des gens qui croyaient
que l'élection présidentielle serait
facile et je n'en ai jamais été ni de
près ni de noix d'abord parce que un peu
d'expérience pas mal d'expérience permet
de se faire prier en ciel le permet de
se souvenir qu'une élection
présidentielle c'est jamais facile c'est
toujours avec des coups de théâtre il ya
une deuxième considération
au bout du compte
ce que les français choisiront c'est
quelqu'un qui est le plus
dense le plus volontaire le mieux armé
pour cette fonction et je crois que
emmanuel macron dans les tableaux que
nous avons aujourd'hui est le plus dense
le mieux armé le plus volontaire pour
cette fonction alors elle a quand même
gagné vous la connaissez valérie
pécresse à l'asvel avait même des
conseillers régionaux modem en
ile-de-france qu'elle dirige a même
suscité cette élection une division
entre des gens de jeu de chez vous qui
sont allés avec elle et d'autres qui
sont allés avec la liste de d'emmanuel
macron dont il était avec elle dans
l'eure dans la majorité il y en a qui
sont allés avec emmanuel macron met donc
pour voilà vous via une forme de
proximité de fait
entre vous et valérie pécresse au sens
où vous venez l'udf ll était à l'ump on
va tout ça c'est c'est une forme de
famille quand même assez proche donc je
vous pouvez considérer qu'elle a des
atouts vous dire quelque chose d'abord
je déteste l'espèce de 2
d'affrontement systématique à laquelle
la politique mène
donc je ne vois pas en valérie pécresse
un ami du genre humain je suis pas
d'accord avec un certain nombre de ces
orientations ou plus exactement ou plus
exactement le le les choix qu'elle a
fait il ya eu mari grâce dell qui m'a
enfin que je trouve surprenante elle a
dit jusqu'à maintenant j'ai parlé à la
droite et maintenant je vais parler à la
france j'ai parlé au peuple de droite je
vais parler au peuple de france comme
s'il y avait deux langages comme si on
était avec un langage spécialistes et la
primaire et pierre belet a été les les
voyelles ça veut dire que c'est un
double jeu pas dire ça aussi durement
mais avoir deux langages ça n'est pas
avoir l'authenticité la volonté la
sincérité que la vie politique comme je
la conçois demande j'ai jamais vu
macron avoir un langage pour les uns en
langage pour les autres mais vous êtes
peut-être le sel
parce que c'est la définition du en même
temps la définition du en même temps ces
denières à tartas vous voyez à quel
point on peut faire une erreur d'
analyse le en même temps c'est d'être
capable de dire je peut réconcilier des
inspirations différentes et je pense que
on peut être je vais prendre un exemple
simple on peut être français patriotes
amoureux du pays amoureux de sa langue
est profondément européen
ça c'est le en même temps on à valérie
pécresse aussi à l'ol pourrait dire la
même chose non contrairement à marine le
pen à eric zemmour ou à d'autres gens
mais elle a encore une fois il ya des
gens qui ont pu dire à certains moments
ont pu se dire pauvre européen et à
d'autres anti européen je fais pas de
polémique avec qui que ce soit mais vous
voyez bien ce que ce que je vous dis ce
n'est pas la même chose
ce qui caractérise le président de la
république selick ce qu'il est capable
de voir ce qui unis les gens au lieu de
ceux qui de ceux qui les divisent qui
les affrontent kylie kylie
table les uns contre les autres et ça ce
n'est pas de langage c'est absolument le
même c'est le langage du président qui
réunit les français et ça je trouve ça
non seulement beau ou des six mais
indispensable pour cette fonction mais
quand vous voyez cette famille a l'air
qui a l'air de s'être réconciliées qui
semble en tout cas on verra et qui
semble se révéler coûteuse info ce
week-end oui j'ai dit qu'il semblait
c'est ça et qui ça veut dire aussi
peut-être que les les parties se
reconstitue ben j'espère bien le il n'y
a pas de vie démocratique sans partis
politiques et même c'est la constitution
comme vous savez congé car si on dit que
les partis politiques ont donc pour
mission de
concourir à l'expression du suffrage
c'est à dire d'organiser le débat pour
qu'on puisse avoir des propositions
différentes et des concurrents sur ce
point donc je suis c'est pas moi qui
peut dire le contraire j'ai toujours été
militant d'une d'un courant politique et
je le reste la maison commune ça fait
pas un peu quatrième république non pas
du tout la maison commune c'est là le le
rassemblement de toutes les forces qui
au centre soutiennent le président de la
république le soutiennent depuis 2010
est pour son élection qui ont permis son
élection et qui aujourd'hui disent faut
plus se perdre dans des querelles de
chapelle il faut être capable de
s'entendre alors est-ce que c'est fait
je vois votre question c'est comment
sait on a pris la décision de le faire
ça reste à bâtir et pour moi ça devrait
aller beaucoup plus loin naturellement
parce que vous voyez bien que dans une
vue politique aussi ballotté de dérive
en dérive
2 deux maux insupportables mise en mot
insupportable
on a besoin d'un
pilier central qui rassure tout le monde
quittait la maison jeu quand même un
dernier mot sur valérie pas casser ce
que vous êtes inquiet de cette
candidature à ce qu'elle vous inquiète
nom vous dit cern ça quand même la plus
difficile pour les manier maman donc je
sais bien que les journalistes écrivent
ça mais je ne fais pas de la politique
avec des inquiétudes je n'ai jamais
pensé que l'élection serait facile je
n'ai jamais pensé qu'on aurait des
adversaires ou des concurrents qui
servirait sur un plateau la victoire à
cette élection je sais qu'elle sera très
difficile et c'est normal qu'elle le
soit parce que c'est un peuple qui
choisit son destin en choisissant celle
ou celui qui le conduira et
c'est lourd de conséquences j'ai souvent
dit vous savez le
celui qu'on va élire c'est comme si on
choisissait le chauffeur du bus des
enfants je disais ça quand j'étais moi
même candidat à cette élection c'est à
dire quelqu'un à qui on confie ce qu'on
a de plus secret de plus intime
on est prêt à lui céder
la responsabilité la plus importante au
nom de vos enfants pas seulement votre
nom au nom de vos enfants et ça pour moi
c'est évidemment très important et
écouter ce que disait eric zemmour à son
meeting de villepinte sur emmanuel
macron
macro à vider de leur substance notre
économie notre identité notre culture
notre liberté notre énergie nos espoirs
nos existences il est temps de sortir
notre pays et notre peuple de ce puits
sans fond nous le laisserons dans sa
vitrine ce mannequin de plastique cet
automate qui errent dans un labyrinthe
de miroirs se masquer son visage qui
défigurent le nôtre nous laisserons cet
adolescent se cherche et éternellement
sinon
c'est nul
que souley qui peut
écoutant seul à
mettre ses mots en rapport par exemple
avec la responsabilité ou la place que
le président de la république occupe
aujourd'hui dans les affaires d'europe
et du monde qui peut qui peut
reconnaître ça
s'il ya quelqu'un qui par ces mots n'est
pas à la hauteur c'est ce que eric
zemmour vient de faire à votre devant
votre caméra
la france mérite pas qu'on fasse
descendre le débat aussi bas alors il ya
des gens qui détestent
tel ou tel candidat tel ou tel président
et dieu sait que depuis des années on en
a vus mais la responsabilité de
quelqu'un qui veut faire
naître le débat concourir à l'expression
du suffrage donner à l'élection
présidentielle sa véritable dimension
c'est précisément de ne pas descendre
dans ses bas fonds de l'eau dans les
bas-fonds basse vous venez de l'entendre
c'est c'est exactement ce qu'on a vu là
bon voilà
ceci n'est pas pour moi la démocratie
que la france mérite pourquoi personne
ne rit pas dans la majorité pourquoi
est-ce qu'il ya pas une bataille
politique plus clair la tient écoutez il
ya une bataille politique à condition de
regarder les vrais objets de cette
bataille politique
il a appelé son mouvement ils veulent
appeler son mouvement reconquête il dit
reconquête parce que reconquista la
reconquista vous savez ce que c'est
c'est au xvème siècle ça ça a duré
plusieurs siècles c'est la guerre contre
les musulmans et contraint les juifs par
les l'inquisition là isabelle la
catholique non c'est plus compliqué que
ça enfin donc c'est la reconquête par
les ddc c'est la guerre à mort contre
les musulmans
et qui a fini en même temps par
l'expulsion des juifs un commercial
parce que tout ça c'est pareil si on
considère que
l'autre celui qui n'a pas la même foi
que vous ou la même culture que vous il
faut le chasser il faut les expulser il
faut en faire la cible universelle
alors
il ya plusieurs autres il ya plusieurs
différends et c'est ce qu'a montré
l'histoire et est toujours extrêmement
éloquente elle vous apprends des choses
c'est ce qu'a montré la reconquista et
bien vouloir dans un pays comme la
france qui a tellement besoin qu'on se
respecte et qu'on se comprenne
dans un pays comme la france vouloir
prendre ce principe de guerre pour
chasser ceux qui ne sont pas comme vous
alors ça quelque chose de glaçant et en
tout cas ça ne peut que finir mal mais
françois bayrou si vous faites dans les
sondages d'aujourd'hui
l'addition de tous les candidats de la
droite de marine le pen
à valérie pécresse en passant par eric
zemmour dupont aignan et cetera et
cetera vous arrivez à 50% est ce que un
pays qui à 50% dit qu'il est de droite
parfois d'extrême droite de droite où on
voit toutes les nuances de la droite est
ce qu'un pays qui fait ça peut choisir
un président centriste un président mais
moi je vous dirais et humaniste et
progressiste mais que certains des héros
qui atteint
voilà ce n'est pas un mot à moi mais
précisément votre addition est fausse
parce que pour additionner on ne peut
additionner que des semblables initial
les électeurs on peut pas non on ne peut
pas additionner ce qui est en
contradiction
et moi je ne crois pas que la droite se
résume à ce que vous indiquez moi je ne
crois pas que la droite je n'ai jamais
été de leur parti mais j'ai tout à fait
souvent il m'est arrivé de travailler
avec eux de discuter avec eux de
dialoguer avec eux comme il m'est arrivé
de discuter de dialoguer avec des gens
de gauche on va dire respect ça voulait
dire que ce sont des droites
irréconciliables ce sont des droites qui
ne peuvent pas travailler ensemble et
qui ne sont pas d'accord que je ne fais
pas d'amalgamé je je je prends en compte
les les différences et la véritable
nature des gens je suis radicalement
opposé
et je les ai toujours été à ceux qui
n'ont qu'un rêve ou qu'un qu'un qu'une
ligne c'est d'opposer les gens entre eux
ça pour moi ce sont des ennemis de la
patrie
les gens qui le
quiconque aime mais n'est pas valérie
pécresse là dedans une femme en voile à
quiconque aime la france alors celui là
forcément
il veut qu'elle soit rassemblé 7 c'est
un vous savez ce qu'on appelait en
joaillerie une pierre de touche à rien
et touchent c'était pour savoir si
c'était de leur groupe à le la pierre de
touche de quelqu'un qui est
patriote est français c'est qu'il veut
le rassemblement du pays et qu'il ne
supporte pas qu'on organise la guerre
civile à l'intérieur et donc pour moi je
ne fais pas l'addition entre les
électeurs que vous voulez mettre dans la
même colonne moi je me garde les
sondages et je vois qu'il ya des à
travers chaque sondage il ya des
porosités d'électeurs il ya des va et
vient et c'est donc il se passe des
choses dans cette famille au sens large
et qui fait que alors à moins que vous 5
emmanuel macron se lance dans une
campagne qui soit dit activement adressé
à ses électeurs de ceux là ceux de
valérie pécresse ses électeurs de droite
par exemple avec un edouard philippe par
exemple l'allemagne l'alsace écran se
présente à cette élection ou quand il se
présentera si merci side de se présenter
il fera pas une campagne comme ça ferait
une campagne pour parler à la france et
ces gens là que vous que vous désignez
que vous que vous étiqueté bas ils sont
des français comme les audiences hier et
le et ceux qui sont catholiques y sont
français comme les autres c'est qu'ils
sont agnostiques ou athées et ceux qui
sont musulmans je ne fais pas de
différence entre les français je fais
des différences entre ceux qui portent
atteinte à l'unité nationale
mais je ne fais pas de différence j'ai
une toute dernière question extrêmement
rapide avant qu'on parle de votre votre
note et xénon il a appelé aujourd'hui
les maires alpa rennais est ce que vous
trouvez que ce serait pas démocratique
s'il n'avait pas ses parrainages la
constitution a fixé 500 parrainages j'ai
été candidat à l'élection présidentielle
trois fois et je sais très bien que ce
n'est pas facile à atteindre mais je ne
vais pas jouer au billard à trois bandes
c'est à dire je vais pas demander à des
mères qui sont de ma sensibilité de
soutenir des gens marine le pen
zemmour
mélenchon valérie pécresse ou mélenchon
je pense que quand on est maire en est
responsable et aucun maire ne se
laissera tenir la pluie la note que vous
avez publié aujourd'hui c'est le dernier
rapport du de votre du haut-commissariat
sur la réindustrialisation de la france
donc c'est quand même un bilan assez
sombre que vous dressez c'est un bilan
de ces de ces trente dernières années
oui c'est aussi de ces cinq dernières
années avec un commerce extérieur
traître est en déficit de 90 milliards
peut-être d'euros pour 2021 et avec des
phrases très forte la france championne
dans l'ex porte dans l'export de pommes
de terre et de bois rond mais dépendante
de ses voisins pour la confection des
chips et de la fabrication des meubles
nous savons fabriqués des satellites des
fusées des avions mais nous sommes
incapables de nous fournir est de
fournir des machines à laver nous avons
abandonné ce territoire là alors ces
territoires ces territoires la
d'industrie précisons ce que vous avez
dit ces dernières années les trois
dernières années elles sont marquées par
le fait qu'il ya un petit redressement
par le fait que les investissements se
sont améliorées l'emploi industriel a
augmenté et c'est la première fois
depuis 20 ans donc il faut voir ce signe
positif mais quand on regarde le bilan
du commerce extérieur ce que nous
vendons est ce que nous achetons ce que
nous savons produire et ce que nous ne
savons pas produire alors en effet il ya
de quoi s'inquiéter ce cas qui est fait
comme vous savez ce n'est pas la
première fois que je dis ça dans ma vie
bien sûr il fait une campagne
présidentielle sous deux verbes produire
et instruire on a besoin de produire et
ceux qui ont abandonné la production
sont coupables et on a besoin
d'instruire c'est une autre question
elle est majeure et tous les candidats
aujourd'hui à la présidentielle déclarée
puisque maintenant on est quasiment la
fin du casting
veulent la réindustrialisation de la
france mais aucun ne propose une méthode
jean propose une alors justement c'est
ce que j'allais vous demander qu'est ce
qui fait que vous avez la bonne recette
de beau jeu je parle avec prudence parce
que c'est des sujets terriblement
compliqué mais encore une fois c'est des
sujets sur lesquels j'ai investi d'une
partie de ma vie politique c'est pas
c'est pas neuf dans dans mon parcours ce
que je préconise c'est au lieu de faire
des grandes déclarations et des
déclarations de principe je préconise
qu'on parte de la réalité j'ai analysé
nous avons analysé dans cette note un
peu plus de 900 produits
et s'est produit un peu plus de 900
c'est tout ce qu'ils font plus de 50
millions de déficit au bout du chemin ça
fait 160 millions de déficit qui
explique pourquoi notre bilan et notre
balance commerciale est si mal elle
dégradée et je demande qu'on regarde les
produits que nous sommes en mesure ou en
compétences de produits
comme vous l'avez rappelé nous savons
faire des satellites les meilleurs du
monde où parmi les meilleurs du monde
sans faire des fusées parmi les
meilleurs du monde pour cela on faire
des avions savons faire des sous marins
nous savons faire des navires nous
savons faire des voitures qui sont pas
si mal et nous sommes incapables de
faire des produits électroménagers or j
aimerais ce qu'on fait alors alors hier
ça s'expliquer parce que hier le coût de
la main d'oeuvre vous savez qu'on nous
atteint pas lisez avec cette question
pendant très longtemps en disant
monsieur bayrou pouvez pas dire qu'il
faut produire en france vous savez vous
savez bien qu'on extrême orient vous
allez trouver leur de travail à 10 fois
moins cher que chez vous c'est ça qu'on
nous disait tous les temps te sûr
aujourd'hui c'est différent surtout des
plates et aujourd'hui c'est très
différent parce que l'automatisation la
robotisation les algorithmes
tout cela que nous sommes tout à fait
capables de produire suffit de regarder
les usines automobiles que nous avons
cédé c'est extrêmement robotisés nous
sommes en situation à cause du numérique
grâce à la robotisation et grâce à notre
électricité avec le nucléaire ne faut
jamais oublier que
on va devoir décarbonés les productions
et nous sommes les seuls ou en tous cas
presque les seuls à avoir une
électricité une source d'énergie
décarbonée si nous sommes capables de
mettre tout ça ensemble est de réunir
autour de la table l'état la puissance
publique les collectivités locales et
les entreprises
ce qu'on ne fait jamais qu'on n'a pas
fait depuis très longtemps qu'on n'a pas
fait depuis jean monnet bon au plan que
faisait manuellement mais si le
ministère de l'économie et à l'elysée
vous savez qu'il a qu'il a fait ce choix
exactement quand vous voyez le plan
france 2000 30000 train de le plan de le
plan de relance et le plan france 2030
c'est exactement ce qu'il a fait vous
avez aussi cette prise de type
d'insurrection on n'a pas fait ça voilà
vous avez une autre piste de réflexion
qui est alors c'est peut-être
intéressant parce que c'est assez
original la prise de participations
publiques dans des entreprises
étrangères vous voyez bien
si vous êtes sur un secteur où vous avez
la compétence mais où il n'y a pas
d'entreprise chez vous eh bien je pense
qu'il est intéressant de faire ce que
les chinois en fait qu'est ce qu'a fait
la chine elle a pris tous les secteurs
de production et l a obligé les
entreprises qui voulaient vendre chez
elle à faire ce que l'appel des
joint-venture en anglais c'est à dire
des entreprises
jumelées bon il faut faire barrage les
seize ans dames lécina nous sommes nous
avons des capacités qui ne sont pas
exploitées la priorité des priorités
c'est
réenraciner la production sur notre sol
mais c'est vrai aussi pour la production
agricole etc pourra c'est vrai aussi
pour la production de médicaments ou de
vaccins absolu sur lesquels nous n'avons
pas été très bons alors j'ai une
dernière question françois bayrou sur la
crise sanitaire vous avez été celui qui
a dit je suis pour la vaccination
obligatoire ou l'avait dit et répété ça
n'a pas été le choix du président du
gouvernement mais bon en tout cas on y
est on est dans une forme de dedans tout
cas de la vaccination va très vite et
les augmente on parle maintenant de la
vaccination des enfants qui va être
ouverte à partir du 20 décembre en
france elle a commencé dans le monde
autre pays est ce que vous êtes
absolument pour de la même façon ces
affaires de médecins
ce que j'ai dit vous avez eu la
gentillesse de rappeler ce que j'ai dit
depuis le mois de janvier c'est le jour
en à un vaccin où on est sûr de son
innocuité du fait que ça ne crée pas des
effets secondaires on a aujourd'hui des
dizaines de millions de français sont
comme les milliards des 13 45 millions
d amis me des amis portugais des
diplomates nous raconter que le portugal
est à 85% presque de vaccination israël
est à des taux de vaccinations
80% et nous on y approche on approche
c'est toi là je vous rappelle que on
disait qu'on était en retard sur la
vaccination à vous souvenez de toutes
les polémiques et donc le jour on à ces
millions d'exemple sur les lieux alors
je suis favorable à ce que on examine la
question de la vaccination obligatoire
alors peut-être ya des gens qui
refuseront mais qu'il le déclare
ce que ce que nous avons aujourd'hui
deux de terriblement frappant c'est que
je connais des gens
personnellement et que j'aime bien
qu'ils disent moi je me vaccine ray
quand ça sera obligatoire
c'est étrange mais c'est comme ça
le devoir des responsables publics c'est
de choisir une solution crédible pour
lutter contre une épidémie qui menace
encore de nous paralyser aujourd'hui on
en est comme vous savez vous avez
entendu
on en est au point de s'interroger pour
savoir si on va retourner à des à des
fermetures de lancer pas de boîte de
nuit aujourd'hui de restaurants demain
d'école après demain vous rendez compte
ce qu'on fait un pays alors que les
précautions existe et qu'on sait que la
contamination est moindre et en tout cas
la gravité de la maladie est moindre
merci beaucoup merci d'être venus sur
nos plateaux français